[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Alice Kaplan who is John M mustard
professor of French a specialist of 20th
century France
professor Kaplan works at the
intersection of literature and history
using a method that allies archival
research with textual analysis a writer
and a literary translator she served on
the advisory board of the National Book
Foundation's study of the state of
translation in the United States which
resulted in the establishment of a
National Book Award and translated
literature today we'll talk with
professor Kaplan about her recent book
titled looking for the stranger Albert
Camus and the life of a literary classic
as well as some of the issues involved
in translating books
welcome professor Kaplan glad to be here
let's start with an overview of your
book tell us about it
looking for the stranger is just that
I'm trying to account for the life of
this mysterious and wonderful book
Albert Camus the stranger I think
probably since the 1950s this has been
the French novel that our students read
not just to learn French because it's
often taught for example to teach the
past tense but to learn how to be a
thinking person okay it's it has a
unique status in the Canon of French
literature and there have been hundreds
thousands maybe interpretations of the
novel and I thought what would happen if
instead of giving one more
interpretation I told the history of the
book how it was made under what
conditions was it published how did it
become such a phenomenal success across
the globe it was published at the very
worst moment for French publishing in
the depths of the Nazi occupation and
camera was an unemployed and very ill
ill with tuberculosis writer in the
boondocks of Algeria it really is a
miracle book yes it sounds fascinating
and and why do you think it's such an
iconic book to the French
well if first of all there's it's style
it is it it's almost changed the
evolution of the novel it's written in a
very flat and plain language and the
narrator more so expresses very little
emotion until the end of the book and
you try to understand who is this guy
what is he really thinking you see
nothing of his interior you only see his
response to the world and there's
something about it that makes the world
around him so clear and that makes
people long to understand him so he is
known in France and and in the United
States too as the ultimate
existentialist character I say and what
led you to write this book well I think
I'm not very different than most
Americans who study French the very
first novel I ever read in French
proudly was Kim as the stranger I read
it in a French camp in Bar Harbor Maine
when I was 15 years old it's stuck with
me I think I've read it a hundred times
since I've taught it at all levels and
it's it's the book of my life and how
did you do the research and and doing
the research did anything strike you
differently after having read the books
so many times and that you learn
something new what I've always said is
that I was taught the stranger with
absolutely no knowledge of the fact that
it took place in Algeria and you know
during the 90s you couldn't go to
Algeria because they were in the midst
of a very violent civil war
now you can so the first thing I did
when I started working on the book was
to go to Algiers where Cameron grew up
and to look at all the places where he
had lived both when he was living in the
setting of the novel
in this working-class neighborhood of
his childhood and the places where he
lived when he wrote the novel and seeing
those places changed everything for me
and what way I could imagine him
absorbing the the ambience of Algiers of
working-class Algiers and I could go on
the beach where the famous fight took
place between Rosso and the Arab that
resulted in the death of the Arab it was
some of it is almost impossible to
describe just a feeling of being close
to the writer and then of course I also
read all his correspondence during the
period when he was writing and his
Diaries he kept not not intimate Diaries
but work-in-progress Diaries so you
could actually see the way the book
almost came alive without him even
intending it he was working on another
book altogether and he's suddenly seen
these images of a man condemned to death
and where are these Diaries now well
they're all published they're called
notebook skimmers notebooks there are
three volumes of them and they've been
translated all three volumes they're
just a wonderful tool for getting closer
to cameras process as a writer right
right so as someone and I know you are
fluent in French but as someone who is
not fluent in French reading and English
translation and you having read both
what are some of the issues that you
come across or some things that you
think of and I know in reading your book
you make note about the stranger the
title itself meaning you know an
outsider or a foreigner and maybe not so
much the stranger so those are great
questions because in fact there are two
titles for the stranger the American
edition is always called a stranger the
British is always called the outsider
now some people like to argue that more
so the main character is not a stranger
he's an outsider a kind of alienated
outsider in society and he's also a
French citizen
in a colonial society so these terms
become so complicated
the very first translator of the
stranger into English for both the
English and the American editions was a
man named Stuart Gilbert quite eminent
translator who translated mudhole and
other great writers he really tried to
make the book sound normal more normal
than it is so kami wrote a lot of his
sentences in indirect discourse and
Stuart Gilbert liked to change those
into quoted material so you actually
hear the voice of a person saying
something and Kimi was really shocked
when he first saw the American edition
he paged through it and he said I don't
remember so many quotation marks in the
original and it was unfaithful that
translation was unfaithful then in the
1980s a very gifted translator named
Matthew Ward retranslated the novel and
that's the Edition that I would
recommend to people he understands all
the odd things chemin was doing with
language interesting I was going to ask
you what you think the best version of
this so I'm glad you told us that as a
translator what are some of the things
that you consider when you're working on
it on translating something mm-hmm well
you know the the saying goes that only
3% of the books published in the United
States are translations and I think that
is probably a stronger figure than the
real figure it is so hard to get a book
translated and so a lot of my energy
goes into talking to publishers about
books that I think are really wonderful
it's called there's an expression in
French m-pesa I'm a passer I try to to
get books to cross over into English I
was just working on a beautiful Algerian
novel called algae Lukie and it's a it's
really an essay about living in the city
of Algiers he talks about this
city of elders as a woman he says
Algiers she which works well in French
because the word for city is feminine
but we don't have the masculine and the
feminine so the first draft I had it all
as a she you know and my editors said I
don't know people might think you're
just not a very good speaker of English
and you don't understand we don't say
she we say it for the city so I had to
come up with a device to make the reader
understand that I knew that Algiers is
not as she in English but that it was a
intentional choice right so here at Yale
you've recently founded a new project
called the translation initiative top
tell us a little bit about that and what
you see as its mission and some of its
goals so the mission of the macmillan
translation initiative is to bring
issues of translation together in one
spot we did a study of the faculty i'm
working on this initiative with harold
OGG and Brahm we discovered that there
are something like three hundred and
sixty members of the faculty at all
levels at all schools all across the
campus whose research involves
translation in one way or another and
that translation is much bigger than
literary translation people in computer
science are very interested I mean as we
know there's now Google Translate so
they're fascinating theoretical issues
about whether you can build a
translation machine people in the
military are very concerned with
interpreting and translation I mean
there's not a field in which translation
doesn't live and so we are reaching out
to people across the campus we're
designing working groups were
publicizing events so that if somebody
is interested in translation in any way
they can come to us okay well we will
look forward to hearing more of that
initiative and I thank you for being
here with us
Dane's sharing some of your work it was
a pleasure and thank you to the
macmillan Maryland okay for more
information about professor kaplan and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you